good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight on Saturday night as you
may now have read a 22 year old man
called Anderson Lee Aldridge walked into
a gay nightclub in Colorado Springs and
opened fire by the time he was subdued
by patrons he had murdered five people
and injured another 25.
you've seen this story before but no
matter how many times you've seen it it
never stops being horrifying and it
shouldn't stop violence and cruelty
should always horrify us every single
time we start to become cynical about
the deaths of other human beings we have
lost something essential to our Humanity
unfortunately you're seeing that
so the most obvious question is why did
Anderson Lee Aldridge shoot 30 people
and the truth is we don't know we do
know he was clearly a troubled person
last summer he threatened to blow up his
mother's house with a bomb authorities
had to evacuate the neighborhood during
the four-hour standoff that ensued
eventually he surrendered
you're seeing this video first on CNN
that shows the alleged gunman 22 year
old Anderson Lee Aldrich surrendering to
law enforcement this is just a year ago
in June of 2021 after allegedly making a
bomb threat on his own mother
so after that happened he of course was
arrested and charged with first degree
kidnapping and felony menacing but then
the local district attorney a man called
Michael J Allen did not pursue charges
why we reached out to Allen's Allen's
office today to find out why but he did
not get back to us so we can only guess
we do know what the effect was because
Aldrich was never charged with a crime
and his arrest record was sealed his
violent past did not show up in
background checks threatening to murder
his own mother did not prevent him from
buying a firearm even under Colorado's
so-called red flag law which was
designed to prevent that very thing
so those are the facts that's what we
know so far once again authorities
failed to keep the public safe they
didn't do their job you may recognize
now a pattern because you have seen that
before
as for aldrich's motive in shooting
strangers we can only guess and we're
not going to guess both because guessing
would be dishonest and irresponsible you
can't just make up a story because it
suits your pre-existing beliefs but more
to the point we're not going to guess
because it would dishonor the memories
of the five people who were just
murdered in Colorado Springs
these were human beings they were
Americans they were not props in a
larger ideological war and to reduce
them to that is wrong that's exactly
what many politicians are doing right
now
within hours of the shootings Joe Biden
and his allies used this tragedy as a
pretext for disarming the law-abiding
population of the country we need more
gun control Joe Biden said predictably
notwithstanding the fact that Colorado's
existing gun control laws which are
extensive did not prevent this attack
so it was a contemptible and heartless
and deeply cynical display of political
opportunism
but it didn't stop with gun control
because in fact the Second Amendment is
not the freedom that threatens the
people in charge the most no that would
be the First Amendment which is your
right to say what you sincerely believe
that is the right the first in our Bill
of Rights that terrifies them the most
your words are a greater threat than any
firearm they must censor you or else
they lose power it is that simple
so these horrifying murders in Colorado
over the weekend quickly became a
pretext for yet more censorship of your
speech you are responsible for this they
told you because you said the wrong
things you are guilty of stochastic
terrorism inspiring Violence by your
beliefs
Anderson Lee Aldrich committed mass
murder because you complained about the
sexualizing of children
every time you object to drag time story
hour for fifth graders or point out that
genital mutilation is being committed on
minors which it is every time you say
that you are putting people's lives at
risk
now that seems implausible and yet many
are making this claim many have made it
over the past 24 hours watch for example
Brandy zedrozny of NBC
online including this Libs of tick tock
account which feeds larger media like
Fox news stories what has happened is a
demonization of lgbtq people calling
them groomers and pedophiles this type
of thing whether we can say it's motive
or not what we know is that it's just
another reason why LGBT lgbtq people are
scared
so there it is right there when you
point out the truth indisputably and the
truth is that some adults in this
country apparently a growing number have
a deeply unhealthy fixation on the
sexuality of children when you say that
out loud you get people killed
that is what Brandi zadrosney is saying
and by saying that Brandy zadrosney and
the many people like her are effectively
defending that same deeply unhealthy
fixation on the sexuality of children by
the way it's absolutely real you're not
imagining that it's happening
the evidence is everywhere and it comes
to light on the internet and Brandy's
adrosity and people like her hate that
you are seeing that notice that dreads
not zadrosney is not claiming that Libs
of tick tock is making this up she never
even suggests that she is threatening
them and what she's doing is threatening
them you should know and she's doing
that because they're pointing it out
noticing it's happening is their crime
and once again it is happening
Children's Hospital in Boston one of the
most famous hospitals in the world has
admitted performing double mastectomies
on children for no medical reason at all
there is no scientific justification for
sexually mutilating kids they are not
doing it for a scientifically defensible
reason they are doing it because they
believe in a very specific religious
ideology
that's true
is pointing that out an attack on gay
people of course it is not an attack on
gay people it has nothing to do with gay
people
it has to do with sexually mutilating
children which is wrong
period it should be a crime period
and yet Suddenly It's very common
as we've reported on this show UCSF
University of California San Francisco
Hospital one of the leading hospitals in
the world is doing this as well and
they've said so out loud this is an
actual quote from their website quote
genital surgery is being performed on a
case-by-case basis more frequently in
minors in the absence of solid evidence
providers often must rely on the expert
opinions of innovators and thought
leaders in the field
so your child gets sexually mutilated
genital surgery that is irreversible not
in the basis of science but on the basis
of innovators and thought leaders
it's hard to believe that's happening
that quote was scrubbed by the way after
we reported on it not because it wasn't
a real quote but because it was a real
quote it was too incriminating once
again this is everywhere
a parent in Pennsylvania called Megan
Brock decided to do some actual
reporting on it because actual reporters
choose not to they look away and attack
anyone who wants to know what's actually
happening
so she filed a records request and this
week she obtained a 2017 email from Dr
Nadia dausion at the Children's Hospital
of Philadelphia again one of the most
famous hospitals in the world known as
chop a widely beloved institution that
has helped very many
but in this case what they were doing
shocks the senses
in a communication with now HHS
secretary Rachel Levine
she wrote this quote I'm not aware of
existing literature this is dausion but
certainly it is happening I think we've
had more than 10 patients who have had
chest surgery under 18 as young as 15
and bottom surgery 17.
that's the sexual mutilation of children
for no medical or scientific reason
simply because right now it is
fashionable and consistent with a cult
that has taken over a lot of leadership
of this country but the fact remains
children are being destroyed by this
it should be a crime the people who
commit it should be in jail
but it's not just the sexual mutilation
of children in hospitals this is part of
a larger Trend and the trend is this
adults crossing the line and it has
always been a bright line into deep
involvement with the sexuality of
children that has always been and must
in the civilized society always be the
most forbidden thing it's considered
unacceptable even among prison inmates
but now it seems to be growing in its
prevalence consider the latest ad for
the clothing brand
Balenciaga this was just uploaded on
Instagram as you can see the photo shoot
they're using to sell their products
features a young girl holding a teddy
bear in a bondage outfit
then in case you missed the point the
photo shoot also contains this image it
shows several documents most of them
aren't visible but what you can see when
you zoom in and of course the point is
that you see it is a reference to a U.S
Supreme Court case called Ashcroft
versus Free Speech Coalition that case
struck down a law against kiddie porn
what is this well it is what it appears
to be it's an endorsement of kitty porn
of child pornography what else could it
be we wanted to know so we reached out
today to Balenciaga to get their
explanation and they didn't respond
so we're going to have to take that on
face value and ask
where's the moral outrage we have an
entire industry in this country
comprised of moral outrage merchants
if you've ever been on Twitter you know
what we mean
truly an entire sector of our economy is
devoted to attacking people for falling
short of the mark and here is a high-end
retailer promoting kiddie porn in an ad
on Instagram and nobody notices there's
no boycott there's no front page New
York Times editorial against it
and of course Instagram let the
advertisement run endorsing Kitty porn
and by the way if you have an alternate
explanation for what this was let us
know a child with a teddy bear in a
bondage outfit and a Supreme Court
decision striking down a kitty porn law
displayed on the table what is that are
we jumping to conclusions don't think so
it is what it appears to be it's right
in your face and no one's saying
anything
again Instagram had no problem with this
until Elon Musk took over Twitter
Twitter allowed hashtags that explicitly
linked to child pornography nobody said
anything because crimes against children
are no big deal it's thought crimes that
are the real crimes so if you said
something about it if you were Libs of
tick tock and said wait a second this
seems to be a betting child molestation
which of course
that's what it's doing you're instantly
booted off Twitter
but the links to Kitty porn they're
still there well now they've been
deleted thank God that's one Improvement
so all of this has been happening out in
the open but NBC News hasn't bothered to
report on any of it where is there a
report tonight in Balenciaga pushing
Kitty porn on an Instagram ad no
they're reserving all their energy to
attack you for noticing you're a
stochastic terrorist if you pointed out
and you need to be censored watch
content moderation is a hard task what
we know is that Twitter and where the
bulk of this information is right now
because that's where the biggest
accounts like Matt Walsh
um and lives of tick tock again where
they sort of post this stuff
um what's being done well two days ago
we know that Elon Musk who owns Twitter
now he just reversed the policy that
Twitter did have against targeting and
harassment of lgbtq people against
misgendering transgender people
so here you have people mutilating the
genitals of children running ads on
Instagram promoting Kitty porn and
there's Brandy zadrosney on NBC News
she's not attacking them she's attacking
anyone who notices and accusing them of
attacking gay people once again this has
nothing to do with gay people this is an
attack on the sexual fixation on and
mutilation of the genitals of children
pushing Kitty porn there's nothing to do
with gay people that's an offense
against anyone's definition of decency
and she's effectively defending it and
they all are
you're not allowed to notice it Russia
committed violence you're complicit in
mass murder
well the people who are doing these
things are fine no one attacks them an
ACLU spokesman launched this attack on
Doug Lamborn a congressman from Colorado
watch this he voted against the respect
for Marriage Act and as a co-sponsor of
Marjorie Taylor Green's Nationwide ban
on gender affirming care for Trans youth
huh that's the crime
children having their genitals mutilated
on the basis of no science no actual
real medical guidance no longitudinal
study there's no evidence this is a good
idea but glad is for it so doctors
mindlessly do it and you can't complain
or else you're a murderer
too crazy these are our children can't
put up with it for her part glad's
president declared that because of
Saturday's shooting you need to shut up
while activist Mutual doctors mutilate
children
in terms of trans kids and gender
affirming care the American Medical
Association the Pediatric Association
has confirmed that these are safe
procedures this is finished business
it's politicians and junk science who's
creating some kind of debate or argument
about this
really now we realize she's paid to say
that of course all these activists are
paid to say what they say very
specifically paid aclu's paid to say
what they say
they all are adl's paid to say what it
says
glad is paid to say what it says
but the truth is the no BS scientific
truth is there's no evidence it's safe
where's the 10-year study on that do you
have one oh you don't have one we have
no idea what the long-term effects of
puberty blockers are we have no idea we
can't even guess as the long-term
psychological effects of General
mutilation on a 17 year old or 15 year
old what you have no idea it's safe
you're lying
it's not a safe procedure
we've spoken to a lot of victims of this
barbarism and it is barbarism we did a
whole documentary on it and by the end
of the documentary we were more shocked
than when we started reporting it out
even people who support these procedures
can't actually defend them and that's
the whole point they have to make you
shut up because they don't have any
facts on their side if you're not okay
with child abuse You're a murderer and
it's worked on a lot of weak-minded
journalists who only care about status
and acceptance by the group but there
are a few on whom it has not worked at
the top of that list is Chris Ruffo
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight